no existen evidencias según la onu en un
informe la organización anuncia no haber
encontrado vínculos entre la
radioactividad y la salud de los
habitantes de fukushima víctimas del
accidente de la central nuclear el 11 de
marzo de 2011 a causa de un terremoto de
9 puntos de intensidad y el tsunami que
le siguió la nueva información señala
que algunos niveles de radiación
recibidos por la población fueron
menores que los inicialmente calculados
mientras tanto las autoridades japonesas
anunciaron que siguen investigando lo
sucedido en el peor accidente nuclear
desde chernóbil el fin de semana pasado
visité fukushima y pude experimentar la
pasión de la población local y de los
que se han trasladado allí seguiré
trabajando para que el desmantelamiento
de las centrales nucleares se lleve a
cabo de forma segura y constante para
que se levante la directiva de la zona
designada como eje de reconstrucción y
revitalización y para que se fomente la
inmigración la catástrofe obligó a
cientos de miles de residentes a
abandonar sus hogares pero la vida fuera
de la zona contaminada sea real
gradualmente y los residentes han
regresado poco a poco solo toma de más
para ser sincera creo que la radiación
era mala hasta hace poco ahora no es tan
grave y aveces vuelvo a mi ciudad natal
durante los fines de semana creo que las
cosas se están recuperando poco a poco y
el ambiente ha mejorado para que la
gente vuelva el gobierno japonés que ha
convertido la recuperación de fukushima
en un símbolo de la reactivación
nacional antes de los juegos olímpicos
está animando a los residentes a volver
con ayudas económicas mientras
descontaminar el terreno pero la
población aún siente desconfianza